-our next guest is an
Emmy-nominated actor
you know from his work
in "The Crown," "Downton Abbey"
and "The Imitation Game."
He stars as Hollywood icon
Robert Evans in "The Offers" --
"The Offer" -- Excuse me.
You can watch the finale
this Thursday,
streaming on Paramount+.
Let's take a look.
-Can I get a vodka martini with
a wisp of vermouth and a twist?
Two?
-Uh, it's 11:00 a.m.
-One.
-Yes, sir.
-Everything okay in your world?
-Yeah, yeah.
Why wouldn't it be?
Robert. Robert, Robert.
I loved the script, man.
I love the twists.
I love the tone.
You've really elevated
the idea of a P.I.
-Thanks.
-If there's one thing --
just one small thing --
the conspiracy
is a little hard to follow.
So if you had to, just for me,
if you had to,
talk about "Chinatown,"
the themes, et cetera,
what would the pitch be, man?
-Please welcome to the show
Matthew Goode, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Thank you for being here!
-Thank you very much.
My pleasure.
-This is -- This is
such a wonderful show.
This is a mini series --
a 10-episode miniseries
about the making
of "The Godfather"
and all the incredible hurdles
that had to be overcome.
Do you remember the first time
you saw "The Godfather"?
'Cause I know I certainly do.
-It was just before
I went to drama school,
and I thought I should
probably watch something
that, you know,
might make me a better actor.
And, yeah -- and it was --
I was legal.
It was one of the first times
I was legal
to actually watch an 18 video.
-Yeah.
-Which shows
how long ago that was.
-Were they pretty --
Growing up in England,
were they pretty strict
about that, getting --
-No, not in my local shop
in my village.
I grew up in the countryside,
so it'd be like
you put bubble gum
on the counter,
barely had your head above it,
and then it'd be like
"RoboCop" would go down.
[ Laughter ]
Just cross your fingers
and hope you got it.
-You play Robert Evans,
who's an icon,
and it's such a rich,
I would imagine, fun character
to play.
-I mean...
-Not even -- He is
both a character,
but obviously
he's a real person.
-Yeah, he's a real person.
But, no, yeah,
it was quite daunting actually,
if anything,
because he has such
an extraordinary cadence
and, you know,
and timbre to his voice.
So I spent a lot of time
watching videos on YouTube --
like, old sort of things he did.
So, yeah.
-Just old interviews.
And "The Kid Stays
in the Picture,"
I imagine that was a helpful...
-Oh, that's one of the best,
you know, documentaries ever.
But, no, because actually I
didn't listen to that too much,
because he's like 70 then,
and the rhythm has changed.
-Oh, right, you had to get
the right -- right era voice.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But there's loads of wormholes
on YouTube you can go down.
It's phenomenal.
-And you were -- You had time
for wormholes,
because you were basically,
because of COVID,
just stuck in a hotel room.
-Yeah.
I mean, it was --
Because if you get COVID,
then they, you know,
they shut the production down
and then it costs
a lot of money,
so I was terrified.
So if I wasn't filming,
I'd be in the -- just in
the hotel room, doing homework.
It was quite boring.
I lived like a monk.
-Is it true --
because I feel like
this happens very rarely
for my British friends.
But you actually were stuck
in a hotel long enough
that you actually started liking
American football?
-Yeah. No, that's --
That's actually not even a joke.
What a great season it was.
-Yeah, right?
Thank you. There you go.
[ Applause ]
All it takes --
-Yeah.
-All it takes is
a pandemic and a lockdown.
-But it was like --
But also Sunday's a long day
if you're in that room
on your own,
so you're like, "Three games
I'm gonna watch."
So that's like
nine hours of fun.
And the best game was
Bills against the Chiefs.
-Yeah, one of the greatest games
of all time.
Now you're -- The only thing
I have to say is, I'm so sorry,
they don't always go like that.
Yeah, they're not all...
-I'll take it. I don't mind.
-I want to ask
about the wardrobe,
because this is I think,
a very, again,
iconic era of Hollywood --
'60s, '70s.
-Yeah.
-Robert Evans obviously
had a sartorial style
all of his own.
Did you enjoy wearing
his clothes?
-Well, yeah.
I mean, there were some
pretty strong looks there.
-Yeah.
-I don't love polyester...
-...that much,
and so there is an element
of like, "Well,
it looks great,"
but you're sort of on set
and just itchy.
But it was, you know,
anything for the craft, darling.
[ Laughter ]
-We so appreciate
your sacrifice.
-But also I got -- you know,
because Robert had these --
Really what's iconic with him is
his enormous lenses
that he wore on his face.
So they brought out --
I had like 25 pairs,
and they were like,
"Which one do you think
you'll wear?"
I think, "The lot.
Let's wear all of them."
-You did a wine show
with our friend Matthew Rhys,
and your friend Matthew Rhys.
-Which is I was nearly here
with the...
-Yeah, the two of you were
supposed to come here together.
-Yeah, I think one of
our children's birthdays
got in the way.
-We celebrate
your being a better father
than talk-show host.
Talk-show guest, I should say.
I would be here no matter what.
-It was a great show, though.
-Oh, thank you. Yeah, well --
But you -- I want to ask,
because I've done some
day drinking on this show.
-I saw your one with Lorde.
It was great.
-But there, it takes you
out of you.
A long day of wine drinking,
isn't that...
How was recovery?
You did 10 episodes.
-Well, it was --
I mean, we were doing, I think,
40 wines in a day.
And you know, and Matthew and I
sort of -- we went hard,
at the beginning.
And then you get -- You know,
like five hours into filming,
the director will be like,
"Can we go again, guys?
This is a joke."
And you'd be like, "What?"
And he goes, "The word
[Slurring] 'decision'
[Normal voice]
didn't come out very well."
So, yeah.
You must find that, too, right?
-Yes, but we only --
it's only two hours.
It's smash-and-grab for us.
We're, like, in and out.
And nobody's watching it
to learn anything about wine.
-We don't learn anything.
-No, that comes across.
-We're just idiots, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I have to ask this, though.
You didn't meet Matthew
on that show?
-No, I've known about him
for years,
and we used to meet each other
in, like, costume fittings,
and he'd be getting his trousers
off over that,
and me being like...
And so I'd speak to him
through a curtain,
and then we met on this.
-This is -- I wanted to
show this
because this, to me, is
the most British title of a show
that I think I've ever seen.
And look, everything about
"Death Comes to Pemberley."
[ Laughter ]
-It's an instant classic.
-I feel like definitely --
you're definitely
wearing an outfit
that I'm super psyched
is in
"Death Comes to Pemberley."
And...
-Matthew looks like
he's about to murder someone.
-Yeah.
That's not
the free-wheeling Matthew.
This is after they told him
there's no more wine.
-Oh, I love it.
I mean, he is the nicest,
funniest person
you'll ever meet.
-To watch him seem dour
is a very not --
out of character
with the real man.
-Yeah.
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Congrats on the show.
You are really
a fantastic Robert Evans.
-Thank you very much, Seth.
-Thank you.
Matthew Goode, everybody.
"The Offer,"
streaming on Paramount+.
We'll be right back with
a performance from Jewel.